STEPHANIE WONG: If you've
ever used a static route
to define how traffic can
move between private networks,
then you probably
know how vulnerable
it is to things like
component failures,
or the wind, or squirrels.
In this episode of
"Cloud Networking,"
I'll show you how to
leverage cloud router
to create dynamic
routing and not
have to worry about cute,
fuzzy networking hazards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine you have a VPC setup
with multiple VMs in a subnet.
Each VM's traffic is directed
through static routes
to a cloud VPN gateway
encrypting traffic
to and from your
on-premise network.
This is fine, as long as
you're on-prem network
has a firewall and router
which know how to send traffic
to your cloud VPN gateway.
Now, what happens if you
have two networks on premise?
This would require
you to manually add
static routes in Google Cloud
that expand each VMs routing
table to include new
network paths on premise.
And you need to
reconfigure your VPN
on both ends, which causes
it to drop [RASPBERRY]
and re-establish.
This isn't exactly
fun, especially
for larger organizations who
turn up new testing networks
several times a week or more.
Static routes in
this case can be
painful for a number of reasons.
A topology change
on either network
requires you to manually
update static routes.
Also, static routes can't
automatically reroute traffic
if a link fails.
What we want is a solution where
our networks can automatically
and rapidly discover topology
changes and then route traffic
accordingly so our users
don't sense disruptions.
This is exactly
what dynamic routing
does, which Google
Cloud Platform offers
as Cloud Router.
Now, if a link
fails, Cloud Router
can automatically
reroute traffic
if another path is possible.
It works like this.
When you extend your on-prem
network to Google Cloud,
Cloud Router peers with your
on-prem VPN gateway or router.
The routers exchange
topology information
through border
gateway protocol, BGP.
Cloud Router advertises
subnets from its VPC network
to the on-premise
gateway via BGP.
Then topology changes
automatically propagate
between your VPC
and on-prem network.
A great side effect
can be lower latency
because Cloud Router learns the
on-premise routes through BGP
and lets the network
infrastructure pick the best
route to reach the destination.
If you're using Cloud
Router with VPN,
it frees you from
management headache
for a number of reasons.
You don't need to
statically manage subnets,
like adding and removing
static routes for your VPN.
It scales with your
traffic because it's not
a physical device that
might cause a bottleneck.
And the BGP session informs
each router of local changes,
meaning any new subnets
you add are seamlessly
advertised between networks.
No downtime or manual
changes to routing tables.
Let's walk through
Cloud Router setup.
If you remember from
my last episode,
I had a static route VPN setup.
Let's create a dynamic router
for this VPN setup in US East
by going to the
Cloud Router page.
Here, I'll give it a name.
Select the VPC network
that contains the instances
that you want to reach.
Choose a region where you want
to locate the Cloud Router.
It advertises all subnets in
the region where it's located.
Pick a Google ASN
you're not using
anywhere else in your network.
An ASN uniquely
identifies each network
on the internet
for BGP sessions.
Choose whether to advertise all
subnets visible to the Cloud
Router or create custom routes.
Next, you can add a
tunnel to each VPN gateway
and establish BGP sessions
between the two cloud routers
or with your on-premise
router, which you can check out
in the documentation below.
Cloud Router is the
orchestral conductor
for traffic between your
on-prem and the cloud,
like when using VPN
and Cloud Interconnect.
It helps a growing
network continue
to function in the face of
failures and other furry
rodents to support
scalability and adaptability.
Stay tuned for more.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]